The most powerful element of selling is actually asking.
So if you know that questions are critical,...
...why are you spending more time watching TV reruns than you are developing new questions?
Note, I just asked you a question.
If you know that questions are critical, why don't you have a list of 25 questions...
...that you're certain that your prospect has not heard before....
...and more certain, that your competition is not asking.
The more thought - provoking your questions,...
...the more your prospective buyer will respect you.
The higher that respect level is,...
...the more likely they are to be truthful with you...
...and give you insight into the key factors that will determine the sale,...
...their key buying motives.
They will also begin to share truth about how the decision is made,...
...not who makes it,...
...how the decision is made.
Every minute you're in front of a prospect, they're deciding how much they like you,...
...how much they believe you, how much they respect you,...
...how much confidence they have in you and how much they trust you.
You know, you're trying to qualify the prospect,...
...guess what?
They're qualifying you.
And all of these factors determine whether or not they're going to buy from you.
A sale will always be made.
Either you sell them on "yes"...
...or they sell you on "no".